[Música]
habla más la economía aquí en directo
américa ya está conmigo el estudio luis
méndez preparado para irse a bailar este
fin de semana este nuevo disco de agua
'luis pero vamos a iniciar hablando de
eeuu en materia económica porque hay
datos del desempleo así es raúl de
acuerdo con el departamento del trabajo
estadounidense la tasa de desempleo se
ubicó en 4,6 por ciento en el mes de
octubre la cifra marca un descenso
respecto al mes de septiembre cuando se
ubicó en 48 % un indicador que si bien
es bajo todavía está por encima de la
tasa de desempleo previo a la pandemia
que rondaba el 3 5 por ciento durante el
periodo los empleadores intensificaron
la contratación agregando 531 mil nuevos
empleos la mayor cantidad de este julio
y un resultado que revela según los
analistas que el país podría estar
dejando atrás la recesión provocada por
el brote de kobe 19 veis digamos ahora
colombia donde la asociación de
empresarios de ese país reveló durante
un evento el impacto sobre la pobreza
que ha tenido de la pandemia en ese país
de acuerdo con el medio portafolio de
colombia que cita declaraciones de bruce
macmaster el presidente de la asociación
de empresarios la pandemia de kobe 19
elimino los avances que en términos de
mitigación de la pobreza adelantaba a la
nación en sus declaraciones más master
señala que el 40 por ciento de la
población se identifica con condiciones
de vulnerabilidad y que de cada 100
personas 43 vive con menos de 11 mil 56
pesos al día esto es poco más de dos
dólares y que al menos 15 de cada 100
vive con menos de 4 mil 844 pesos es
decir un dólar 25 centavos en este
sentido destaca que el sector
empresarial es la principal fuente de
inclusión social y de equidad en
colombia' por otro lado en el evento
también participó juan tal y oviedo
director general de la dirección de la
administración nacional de estadísticas
y él señaló la importancia que en la
lucha contra la pobreza debe existir
entre el empleo y el sector empresarial
especialmente en las principales
ciudades del país estas afirmaciones van
en línea con las conclusiones de un
estudio realizado recientemente por el
banco mundial y que fue presentado a
finales de octubre donde se ubica a
colombia como el segundo país más
desigual de américa latina y con al
menos 36 millones de pobres adicionales
producto de la pandemia desplazamos
ahora cuba porque se alista para el
segundo foro empresarial una iniciativa
que busca principalmente la atracción de
inversión extranjera al país y por ello
se espera la visita de al menos 41
representantes de distintos países así
lo dio a conocer el ministro de
inversión extranjera y comercio de este
jueves en este sentido el gobierno
cubano ofrece un total de 503
oportunidades de inversión a los
empresarios extranjeros que muestran
disposición de operar en cuba'
escuchemos nosotros aspiramos a que la
inversión extranjera en cuba
llegué a un nivel de alrededor de dos
mil millones al año ya es un casco lo
que nosotros hemos hecho de lo que
desearíamos tener
existen todos estos obstáculos que
ustedes conocen y tenemos también
nuestros propios problemas
louis la escasez de seis mil conductores
sigue afectando a la industria
automotriz a nivel mundial un anuncio
que ya han hecho varias empresas y hoy
se dio a conocer que la fabricante honda
rebajar a su pronóstico de ganancias
para el presente año debido entre otras
cosas a esta situación sería la segunda
vez que la empresa recorta su pronóstico
de ganancias ya que además de la
situación de los semiconductores el
aumento del acero y otros materiales
está afectando el margen de ganancia en
septiembre la producción mundial de
automóviles cayó un 30 por ciento en
comparación con el año pasado esto de
acuerdo con la agencia de noticias
reuters pero escuchemos qué fue lo que
dijeron los directivos de onda al
respecto el motor motos han cuota cara
'no está en nokia originalmente
esperábamos que el suministro de
semiconductores se recuperara en el
tercer trimestre pero desafortunadamente
el impacto de los bloqueos en asia se ha
prolongado aunque esperamos una
recuperación a partir del principio del
próximo año será difícil recuperarse
durante el término actual
y le pregunta por la tan esperada cifra
el día a usted le gusta el vino me
fascina el vino lo importante porque hay
buenos vinos en américa latina y en
chile particularmente fue la región que
estima una alta producción para este año
con 13.4 millones de hectolitros esto de
acuerdo con la organización
internacional del vino y que no se acabe
ni el vino ni el café louis nosotros nos
vamos ahora directamente hasta parís ahí
ya está lista natalia ruiz para todos
los detalles de la actualidad francesa
así eso algunos